ich wollte auf die toilette gehen ich
mache die tür von 100 sitzen nachdem ich
habe mich so erschrocken wird sitzt mal
so'n zwei kinder auf der toilette etwas
gedacht und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch gesucht also ich muss da
waren ich witze aus sicht von der
müllabfuhr aber irgendwie gefällt mir
der politiker leute ich nehme heute mal
die audio mit meinem handy hier auf weil
mein mikrofon kaputtgegangen ist jetzt
muss ich mir ein neues bestellen ist gar
kein problem ich hoffe es ist trotzdem
gut also ich hoffe der ton des trotzdem
wurde und zwar habe ich heute
beziehungsweise wir wieder was
interessantes vor ich habe ja so ein
format gestartet wo ich die
schlechtesten restaurants aus speziellen
einrichtungen wie in meiner stadt also
in köln
teste und schaue ob die wirklich so
schlecht sind wie es im internet steht
unserem letzten video wird kommentiert
andechs geh doch mal in die schlechteste
eisdiele und ich habe mir gedacht das
wetter ist ja irgendwie für
schmerzforschung post im februar war das
wetter her extrem gut deswegen kann man
ist ja eigentlich schon machen also ein
schönes ist nur der sonne
das ist heute der plan wir gehen
allerdings natürlich in die schlechteste
eisdiele die ich in ganz köln gefunden
haben es ist wie immer in köln gibt es
hunderte von eisdielen die wirklich
eigentlich alle eine gute bewertung
hatten auch diese eisdiele hat jetzt
keine unterirdische bewertung ist
allerdings mit 2,9 stern schon die
schlechteste von einem und man muss
sagen sie hat vor allem im letzten jahr
sehr viele ein sterne bewertungen
erhalten was habe ich mich dazu
entschieden habe
da kannst du dich mal vorbeischauen und
der sachen also ein bisschen auf den
grund gehen machen ja doch irgendwie
spaß so leute und zwar handelt es sich
um diese eisdiele
die ist auch eigentlich ziemlich in der
innenstadt es gab noch eine einzige die
war doch mal um 0,1 sterne schlechter
allerdings war das schon eigentlich gar
nicht mehr köln deswegen ich hatte auch
wirklich kein bock so weit zu fahren
wir schauen uns einfach mal die
bewertung an und da ist natürlich wieder
alles zensiert ich möchte niemandem
etwas böses und wir schauen mal ein sehr
schlechtes eis unfreundliches personal
lokal klein und dreckig mit preisen
außerhalb des normalen die dame ist sehr
unhöflich und dem eis zu machen ist eine
halbe stunde
der schockierende sache dass du dich
scheint da hatten auf jeden fall jemand
richtig auf den tisch gehauen
also vor allem durch den letzten satz
schon hart für dich also muss man ganz
ehrlich zu sagen haben wir wirklich
extrem viele schlechte bewertungen
schöne eisladen zumindest von äußeren
das eis schmeckt leider nicht so gut die
auswahl ist übersichtlich reisen keine
kugeln dass man nicht noch mal hin muss
also verhältnismäßig viele kommentare
die wirklich extrem sauer sind wie der
hier auch zum beispiel ich habe mir
extra ein google konto erstellt und
diese fläche von icido zu bewerten ein
stern zu geben ist schon unangemessen
wenn man diesen laden zu grunde legt
diesen hier fand ich auch noch ziemlich
hart das ist geschmacklich enttäuschend
eigentlich ist mir das schreiben von
google bewertungen zu umständlich aber
diese niveaulose eisdiele hat einfach
nur eine schlechte bewertung verdient ps
für diesen service melde ich mich sogar
in den anderen bewertungs foren an um
auch dort meine bewertung zu
hinterlassen also wirklich anscheinend
ein paar leute die sehr sauer waren
natürlich gibt es auch bewertungen die
dass da nicht verstehen können und dann
will ich auch gar nicht lange lagern wir
fahren los wohl noch einen setup der
kommt nämlich mit ja eine sache noch
über die ich mich mal kurz auf regen
möchte und zwar über die liebe maler sie
hat nämlich geschrieben ich habe gerade
nach einer eisdiele meiner nähe gesucht
hier gerne probiert los nachdem ich die
bewertungen gelesen habe habe ich es mir
doch noch anders überlegt ich mache
jedenfalls eine kuchen im land eventuell
lasse ich mich an einen mutigen tag
gerne vom gegenteil überzeugen und da
stelle ich mir die frage das ist so
typisch deutsch du hast es nicht mal
selber probiert lässt sich von anderen
bewertungen leiten und gibst dann eine 1
sterne bewertung für den laden ab ich
meine wo ist denn da der sind also
urteilt niemals über irgendwas war sie
nicht selber mit eigenen augen gesehen
hat probiert habe wie auch immer und
jetzt geht's los
also leute los geht's zuerst muss ich
aber noch aufholen weil da kommt auch
mit
dann haben wir gleich zwei meinungen und
dann sitze ich nicht immer so dumm
alleine darum bis gleich jetzt aber
schnell ist gerade rot es geht hier kann
doch kein eis essen 100 gesagt das ist
nicht gut natürlich ist das ist nur so
mandant rausbekommt dass es nicht gut
jetzt gesagt nur wenn man die mandeln
rauskriegt ist das übrigens ich glaube
die junge da ist der fahrradweg nicht
vor mir weil ich heute der fahrradweg
ist einfach da immer diese fand dieser
fahrradfahrer fährt ein auto
ich finde es auch gut dass man fahrrad
wird klar
ich fahre auch viel verraten wenn ich
bei meinen eltern bin aber dann benutzt
ja auch den fahrradweg mehrheit noch so
leer geht drüber geht darüber
wo befindet sich die schöne eisdiele
dann lass uns doch mal 150 meter von
hier darf man das nicht zeigen
8 zeigt sicherlich viele das ist auch
nicht dass die giovanni ist nicht die
dinge war nicht aber ich habe schon
herausgefunden wie teuer das stadthaus
man für seine ganzen becher zeit ja das
heißt er sonja so ein spaghetti butter
also stand zumindest im internet so 55
ist das normal
[Musik]
wir sind uns da was müssen
ich will alles nicht mehr so ein
sprecher
[Musik]
so konnten
ja
wir haben uns jetzt nochmal nach draußen
gesehen haben hier kann ich aber nicht
nur eigentlich nicht aus ich habe gerade
machen willst du hier einen tft ich bin
krank ich so zu der hast du honig die
soja kommt zurück und so ergaben
dicksaft und drückte wasser reinigen
das ist etwas komplett anderes ich filme
also meine waffen ist jetzt auch da
sieht eigentlich ganz lecker aus und
jetzt auf jeden fall frisch gemacht das
habe ich gesehen also ich mag
normalerweise sachen nicht so gerne aber
die sagen was ihr komisch ist hier schon
schmecken sind
ich wollte auf die toilette gehen ich
mache die tür von der toilette sitzt
nach rügen ich habe mich zu erschrocken
wird sitzen da sie zwei kinder auf der
toilette
das war ja nein doch die kirchen
drauflegen das komplett ein gewalt nicht
gut doch nicht die sahne ist geil
ausgesagt haben sie können ja gesagt
leute ihr müsst euch vorstellen wir
haben gerade so 9 grad oder so und wir
sitzen jetzt es leid und das lustige ist
von unseren wollen überall influenza die
wollen doch collins und was sagst du
also an sich was echt gut es gab halt
nur ein paar witzige situation würde ich
jetzt mal sagen die waren halt wurde
also um aufs klo zu gehen
durch diese theke gehen muss ist dass
man also zu denen die wohnung hoch
so leute zurück im auto ich wollte mal
was einfallen wir haben jetzt für ein
schoko becher 57 gezahlt was haben meine
waffe sechs euro und den dreck ziehen
mal 250 oder so bis zu 350 wenn die 16
50 geteilten 16 also ich muss sagen für
mich so also kommen sie auch vom dorf
also für mich ist das sehr teuer aber
alles okay ich meines mitten in köln
da kann man das vielleicht verstehen
aber es hat sich also schon teuer ein
es hat echt mitten mitten in köln
deshalb würde ich auch sagen diese
schlechte bewertung kommt sicherlich
durch nichts wussten die deutschen
liegen ja aber klar auch so durch durch
so touristen die sich denken auch
schönes wochenende in köln ein eis
genießen
mit dieser messe und das halt so eine
italienerin die halt richtig sagst du
hast du die hat uns richtig
angeschrieben so gefühlt aber das ist
denen ihr temperament so die reden halt
so
die war eigentlich auch ganz korrekt die
wahl folgen hätte jedoch am ende gesagt
schönen tag bleibt gesagt wenn du noch
mal nicht rausholen nochmal so die welt
also schon sehr kundenfreundlich
eigentlich ja gut dann ist das das erste
beispiel dafür das ist nicht immer auf
die bewertung dann kommt nehme ich
glaube schon das zweite ich weiß nicht
heute zeigt auf jeden fall die letzten
paar check auf jeden fall mal sex kanal
ab wenn ihr noch schlechtere videos
sehen will als minderwertige niveau
lockte und das war von mir das video
schon zehn minuten
[Gelächter]